[Music]
in donut hustle news submitted by Katie
from Seattle Krispy Kreme strikes a deal
with a college kid who was reselling
their doughnut so he had a good
marketing strategy I don't know if you
guys have had Donuts recently but I did
and I I believe that I that felt like
crack cocaine Oh
Krispy Kreme are just doughnuts in
general Krispy Kreme is the devil yeah I
love Christmas I my stomach does it now
that I'm older and not seven it you know
when it was like okay it doesn't go over
good let you [ __ ] yourself I [ __ ] myself
like like it's not cute okay I feel
pregnant and then my skin looks like you
know how do you cutely [ __ ] yourself
when you do it on someone's like
furniture like a little shape that's
cuter yeah so this guy his name is Jason
he's 21 he would drive 250 miles to
resell Krispy Kreme donuts so he would
drive to Iowa and then return it to
Minnesota and so he would do these trips
constantly and he even created a
Facebook page called Krispy Kreme run in
Minnesota and he ended up messing more
than 5,000 followers so he had a really
good girl who's like post mates but for
Krispy Kreme only pretty much long
distance yeah long distance cuz they're
not gonna be like warm and fresh or yeah
so initially he got the idea to pick a
box of the Krispy Kreme when he was
traveling to coach in a soccer
tournament and he realized like there's
a Krispy Kreme nearby in Iowa so that's
when he came up with the idea so the a
box of dozen of original glazed donuts
start at 9:49 but he would resell them
from $17 to $20 per box depending on the
variety so he said that he was he was
doing this in order to continue to go to
college and not have any debt like
student
oh you look so happy gorgeous ten bucks
and all five thousand people hell yeah
50 G's so like he's able to fit a
hundred boxes in his card
what yeah they sold the mana boxes so
Steve from the thing that you saw at the
strip club I know Sartre is a different
episode what with what numbers-wise how
does that work out would you sell Krispy
Kreme or be a stripper so I would still
dance you don't have to drive his money
no one else
oh lucky one RP would you sell Krispy
Kreme or would you the question for the
audience is would you so Chris became or
would you strip because you can make a
lot of money on private dances this
still seems like really lucrative he
does and you don't have to be in tip-top
shape exactly you living large you
especially don't have to be in to
crochet doing that man those stripper
numbers Oh like you can be like a
million dollars a years mm-hmm
I don't know if you can make a million
dollars but I do it SID you only have to
get like for private dances a night
think about that about it just the
self-respect that what will that cost
you know what comes a great benefits to
ya benefit just what about the mental
health plan did you get that to him I
don't think I don't think that comes
with the top job mm-hmm all right so
Jason after 19 successful runs he ended
up posting on his page on October 31st
this which reads hi all I bear some bad
news unfortunately the run for this
Saturday will not be taking place as I
have been told I have to shut down
operations I figured it would come
eventually but it arrived early with the
surrounding articles life happens and it
could be a sign that something else is
meant to be appreciate everyone's love
and support to make this happen couldn't
have done it without you all I would
love to connect with some of you via
LinkedIn if you don't wouldn't mind why
oh you can add me on Facebook as well as
maybe I will have another
entrepreneurial adventure you will be
interested in as I would love to follow
some of you as well thanks everyone
so then on November 4th he posts again
and he says hi everyone here is the next
important update I am pumped to announce
that I will be able to continue the
business
soon and have the support of Krispy
Kreme they want to ensure I become an
independent operator and make sure the
brand is represented well on both ends
there are things that are being worked
on right now to achieve that as this is
being made as a special exception but
nonetheless we can get started but begin
soon once certain things are in place
this being said I'm definitely going to
need a bigger vehicle with how much this
has grown over the past few days I know
a couple of you have asked about a
GoFundMe I decided to create one because
I won't be able to cover the cost on my
own I realized any donation would mean
the world to me no matter how small
maybe I can decal it with some donut
stickers I'm happy that things turned
out positive and this can continue to
strive and grow over the next couple of
years I've said it before I've said I'll
say it again thank you from the bottom
of my heart to everyone who has
supported me on this journey so he
created a GoFundMe they're like whatever
now he's wanted [ __ ] dollars she's
raised five thousand five hundred out of
ten thousand that's pretty good
go him you look so happy like you just
look so genuine you know it's so sweet
yeah but it's what a sweet little donut
delivery man huh say I was like well
that doesn't work out what's the next
thing like you can do ice cream you know
yeah it's something that's like not
available in that area Minnesota I would
do like California to some other market
Minnesota well he should move well
something else where you can only get it
in other states in that vest yeah in and
out dude is a [ __ ] religion to some
people I don't even know why I haven't
like once every six months who gives a
[ __ ]
like these people are nuts brother like
having burgers better I think I think
it's better it was founded in Santa
Barbara good but no point being it's
better but but there's so much hype
around it that it doesn't even matter
and so I would [ __ ] do that as a
business come on dude did anyone sell
Donuts there have to do anything for
school growing up like you I love
selling chocolate bars and gift wrap and
like Oh remember the gift rather than
getting the brochure and then like
flipping through all the gift samples
that was fun and you can see what cut
like the prizes you would get I got like
a clear one of those clear phones but it
was a pull style phone
almost the gift-wrap say where you hit
it and it goes that's another you know
wasn't a rotary it was a pull style ooh
it's just when you press the button it
doesn't go beep beep boop it goes that
did it
no I got that she was asking no I know
it's the same as a real is like a
regular phone but it's Paul style it
makes a different sound different sound
got it mm-hmm
as making the sound I'm like so are you
moving multiple buttons or like what's
like deep deep yeah you need to post
this on your story I want to see a
visual of the phone I don't know hoarder
well no one has a landline anymore
are you a hoarder oh you have a landline
yes stop judging why because no one my
phone is always on Do Not Disturb
because I get obviously distracted a lot
you know I don't know why just happens
so I never answer like the phone so the
only way to get like delivery is if you
press nine on the home phone because
like no one aunt my mom's always working
with babies and then my sister is always
doing oh I know that's what she had my
card sitting at the clicker cuz the baby
she's got like a two-seater and then my
car is like like better for babies so I
know well the bit this baby was sick so
she had to go to hospital with the baby
so I was just like well yeah I know
don't bring your kids around sick people
as you know and if your kid gets sick
you guys get sick right yeah isn't that
the worst do you guys think about that
before you drop them off the playground
Oh Papa moss sorry and then like take
you know drop them all inside since
childhood just like little glimpses it's
like I don't know I'm just gonna take
the kid to the park I'll put like a
little football helmet on him or
something and I'm gonna go on the ball
like that shirt my gonna know you don't
get scared or like the balls what about
the vault do you let them go into the
balls and do they still have it yeah
hasn't been in a ball
actually yeah Oh your information a lot
a lot of information yeah like show
polygons yeah more that you don't have
that don't even make eye contact just
cut it out Syd I'm sorry I'll do the
rest the interviews like this okay I'm
thinking god I got my nails done but
yeah we're talking about donuts here
well yeah I thought we were talking
about teams they know we're in a
different one aren't we she was
convinced that's tight save you tight
your Energy's awesome thank you guys I'm
not gonna look at any of that's a
different one thing different everyone
to see teleporting from video to video
yes dang that's a different one - dude
were D we're actually in a playlist
video of Syd yeah yeah yeah
James Rodolfo's work got cut into like a
fraction this is one video [ __ ] James
Dean I mean would you if you could hook
up with James Dean whatever don't stop
what is your favorite doughnut what is
your favorite doughnut Krispy Kremes
glaze why do you want to know I didn't
mean what do you care what my favorite
donut is this private information I'm
trying to commit okay yeah I just like
the og glaze those regular I don't like
all the other ones are too sweet
oh my favorite one the one doing that
it's like crumble stuff on top sprinkles
I don't know yeah I know you're talking
about like the brownish one brown
crumble [ __ ] yeah I didn't like those
cuz they were ugly when I like when I
was a kid I was like you notice ugly oh
when I was a kid it was a different
doughnut it was the white frosting with
the sprinkles oh that's my favorite as a
kid but then yeah I just always go for
the prettiest one which one was that a
pink with sprinkles
this is leave it I'd actually don't like
donuts I just thought it was really
pretty so I wanted to eat is it too
sweet
yeah like that yeah I don't like the
cakiness of it like high fat things
really gave me a headache for some
reason so I didn't like ice cream I
didn't like donuts I didn't like butter
I didn't like mayonnaise
I don't like cheese or any of that but I
would get muffins usually when we went
to the doughnut thing when I was store
on the store this story
yeah no words anymore anyway I'm not
gonna tell you my favorite doughnut you
know it's it look at me look at me it's
none of your [ __ ] business
yeah it is because we're here
and it's a public information I should
know this but whatever it's fine I don't
need to know I don't know anyway girl my
mom brought home some because my mom is
like all nostalgic about she's like in
the 70s I used to follow I'm like mom
it is 2019 okay I can only Photoshop so
much stop buying this [ __ ] and it makes
me not feel good a Photoshop your mom's
food well no it means make eye contact
if she eats it wait though you don't
have one
well she got pumpkin and I ate seven of
them do you have one and you can't just
have one can any can you test me okay
good have just one look at you and your
self-control that's nice to have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]